(gentle orchestral music)
- [Narrator] These days,
synthetic dyes are everywhere.
Ninety-nine percent of fabrics
are dyed with chemicals
we can barely even pronounce.
But before there was
azophloxin, chrysoidine R,
and Xylene cyanol FF, there was saffron,
madder root, and tree bark.
In Kyoto, Japan, Sachio
Yoshioka and his team
are creating dyes the
traditional way-with plants.
(bouncy string music)
(foreign language)
Chemical dyes are bad for the environment
and end up polluting the
Earth's water supply.
Sachio and his team use
locally grown plants
to create their bright and colorful dyes.
(foreign language)
The natural dyes are
used to create fabric,
which is made into
traditional Japanese costumes
but also everyday wares.
(foreign language)